well this feels like a big moment for
you because you know you started so
young did pitch perfect but now you're
the first female lead ever and the
Transformers franchise it's I am
everyday it's like I have these moments
of realization that is this is happening
this is real I you know we're in LA I've
been seeing my face on billboards all
over town and I grew up here and I grew
up in the city auditioning for parts and
roles that I would dream and hope and
pray that I would get and and wouldn't
and those billboards would be all over
town and now it's me so it's quite
surreal and really an honor are you
looking at yourself like I mean
literally in the car like how slow can
you drive through this intersection I
just want it and I know your family
supported you so much what is it like
for them to see you have this I mean I
they I wouldn't be here without them and
I'm just so excited to share this with
them this again is something that means
a lot to me they get to see it for the
first time in a couple days with me so a
little nervous but very excited I get to
have them a part of everything I do very
thankful that they want to be and yeah
I'm excited for them to see it by the
way just heard that your brother is in
the movie because he helped with the
driving that's right so my my older
brother Griffin is a racecar driver
slash mechanic slash everything you are
having to do with cars he is a genius
and he was on set with me while I was
making this movie which was so helpful
in so many different ways just to have
him help make sure everything I was
doing felt real and authentic especially
when it came to working underneath the
car and there was a moment where he
actually drove the car for a specific
part because there was nobody that could
get the car to do what the director was
looking for so he was there he Keith
kind of swooped in and saved the day it
was pretty cool fair smooth right yeah
but nothing movies a family affair not
mom and dad really well it again it's
such an amazing time and so you have
your brother John Cena I mean what's it
like working with that guy I mean he is
wonderful honestly his ability to snap
in and out
character is just very very impressive
just loves to have a good time has the
best sense of humor and brought so much
to this role I think really nobody else
could have he has such a presence which
is so important to his character and
yeah he was I mean always incredibly
prepared which was you know I mean me on
the other hand he was great waiting we
are you like a copper miner five minutes
later Lee Holman well no it's just that
moment of like you get to it you get to
set everybody's got sizing hands you're
like alright we're gonna read through
this or whatever and I would always have
it on me just to you know just have it
on me cuz why not and everybody always
be like John do you need a parent oh no
I got it it's all up here just like wow
alright cool great same I'm gonna throw
these out the window yeah no I have
everything yeah yeah well he's like his
focus is insane insane what's kind of
your how do you get prepared for this
you know for when you're gonna come to
set especially in a movie like this
where you doing stunts getting tossed
around oh yeah there really is no way to
prepare I feel obviously you go through
some physical training and if there are
certain stunts they are you know right
there to show you exactly how to do it
step-by-step but when it comes to
working on a film like this I learned
that it was really just about being
super present in the moment and there
was never a dull day or moment in time
really while making this film like you
said it was always there was I was
either driving at very high speeds being
tossed around or rolling around and
something jumping from one object to
another 150 feet up in the air there's
you know there's no way to prepare for
that other than just showing up and
doing your best just praying what yeah
they're my exactly I'm Charlie Watson
I'm 18 today actually it's the beetle
for sale
yours kid happy birthday
I gotta ask you by the way but you have
this insane Colorado girl cigarette
going yes let's talk about your and
literally wrote down
Luke's like oh thank you Thomas promote
or yeah
are you feeling like I'm having a
fashion moment I'm gonna love this right
oh my goodness up Tallulah I mean this
is like this is the time I I love that
part of what I do allows me to wear some
of the most incredible clothes and shoes
and coats talk about the boots those
like lace-up yes you had on how long did
that take did that take to put them on
and I was hoping you'd asked about I
want to say like 12 minutes per boot
yeah boot it was not easy it was not
easy and it was one of those things
where then you know we had like a solid
30 minute car ride from where we were
going from where we were to where we
were going and it was one of those like
I'm just gonna I'm just gonna sit like
this the whole way let us know when
we're there okay don't stop and don't
take out quickly cuz you know very
uncomfortable situation and I can't feel
my feet exactly or might like for that
matter right or do you feel like I mean
you've gotta feel pretty fierce it looks
like that of being in the center of
attention on this movie I mean it
honestly just feels so surreal like I
said before this whole experience being
able to travel the world and share this
film with so many people is is really
special and again getting to where some
pretty great outfits on the way isn't so
bad either what words come to mind when
you think like how do I feel on this
outfit and not yeah specifically ooh I
mean I don't know I was we were in
Berlin and you know I was I was sort of
under the impression that it will II was
this exclusive fan screening and I've
been to a couple of those before for
films that I've been in and you know
we're like jeans and t-shirt and it's
totally casual and I got out of a car
and this was like a whole Center like it
felt like the city was just like decked
out and Bumblebee everything there were
posters everywhere the those massive
screens in this sort of little town
square we were in playing trailers from
the film this massive
the I mean it was like this whole thing
so just to be there first of all I
actually had a moment where I was like
I'm so glad I'm wearing what I'm wearing
cuz it fits so well so yeah you didn't
want to be underdressed for them no no
the boots came to play